dr. Felix Ruiz of wan-koo bomba Carew
was opposed to drug experimentation
until a fatal accident shattered his
life he'd gotten an emergency call the
ambulance was rocketing across town when
a child chasing the stray marble ran
into the street when I got down and was
able to verify that the boy was my
nephew it really affected me I had
nightmares pains in my neck pressure on
my chest and my breathing was agitated
psychiatrists couldn't help in
desperation
dr. Ruiz went to the mountains hoping to
find relief in a drug ritual he drank a
soup made of a cactus called San Pedro
the brew causes hallucinations visions
many Peruvians believe can change lives
I started to sleep peacefully I no
longer had the nightmare I no longer
sweated at night life slept normally in
Peru the only taboo against San Pedro is
taking the drug on your own custom
dictates a collective experience guided
by a shaman the pilgrims have brought
symbols of their problems this is the
alter are objects that have energy for
curing and what they're taking out are
personal things photographs their
perfumes everyday objects that have
energy for the curious Jose Galan lost
everything when his business failed for
years he struggled to make a living
finally he got a bank loan to open a
bakery then disaster hit Jose claims
jealous neighbors wrecked his ovens Jose
believes that by taking San Pedro he can
restore his good fortune but first he
and the other pilgrims must cleanse
their minds and their bodies the seekers
are now ready to meet the shaman who
will guide their drug journey he's known
as el maestro el maestro is a hands-on
shaman twice a week for 47 years he's
taken vast quantities of San Pedro he
believes this takes him to a spiritual
realm where he can change the lives of
those who seek his help
el maestro decides who can take San
Pedro and how much Jose takes his dose
within minutes the drug kicks in during
the eight-hour high the Pilgrims weave
between exhaustion and exhilarations
believers say this enhances the drug
strength the trip ends at dawn when the
seekers can return to their lives their
faith in themselves restored using the
insight of San Pedro el maestro told
Jose occurs on his house had ruined the
bakery so Jose and his wife are going to
move elsewhere to grow rice well now we
are content happy because everything is
faith dr. Ruiz still doesn't know how
San Pedro helped him overcome the
tragedy of his nephews death but he
believes his experience is real rooted
in a culture that has been using
medicinal plants for thousands of years